people don't understand like I mentioned
when you arouse yourself with these
things you're opening yourself up to a
whole nother world that people don't
understand and as you mentioned the
people the musicians playing with the
Ouija board people don't know what these
people are doing behind the scenes
there's a reason these these are these
women and these people are screaming in
the crowd for them they're utilizing
many people are utilizing the assistance
of the jinn to a system and their
performances and everything people don't
realize these things this is a whole
nother reality especially many of the
Muslims are very ignorant towards this
fact they don't understand that this is
a whole nother element it's just not
something that's you know friendly and
things like this no you are inviting
these things into your home on a deeper
level you know you're inviting these
things to your home and everything so
when you're talking about the jinn and
these things like this I'll give you an
example from a personal experience Eddie
I can tell you that when I was a
non-muslim as I mentioned to you guys to
play various instruments I can tell you
that it literally felt like I was under
possession I would do things that I was
not able to do I would play things that
I was not able to play normally that I
wasn't able to play twice and people
musicians may say oh this is the
musician effect okay the word genius
comes from the word jinn so me and a
brother in Egypt I remember we were
having this conversation he's a brother
that knew Jimi Hendrix he knew a lot of
people he's an old-school musician and
he said me and him were playing around
talking about the word genius and stuff
like this he said you know he said when
we say when we think about the word
genius we used to say we used to think
about that person has that jinn he got
that jet reflect on this people like
Jimi Hendrix and he's he was not able to
play without being under a substance
being high without being high so we know
even from a scholarly point of view
whether the scholars mention about
people that get high things like this
you make yourself open to what the chin
every musician that is on the highest
level think about it many of them are
doing
dogs and alcohol to get them to that
level you can't escape it you can you
might as well if you don't want to be
involved with drugs and alcohol or
listening to someone better is involved
in those things you might as well take
all all of your CDs and everything and
just throw it out because this is what
the people that you're listening to this
is what they're involved in many of them
getting high alcohol and as you
mentioned it's not clearly clarifies and
make clear it makes clear the position
on those things so and when we told them
I was soul music one of the people had
people listen to these terms soul music
this is something coming from someone's
soul so what state is that person in
when Neverland that they're laying those
lyrics to you or when they were singing
that song what state was the solder
because you know you may start to feel
the way that person was feeling you
understand this is a serious thing this
is a spiritual thing you're talking
about that's why they know it they call
it soul music yeah they say they throw
terms out this is magic in the making
okay what magic are you talking about
Def Jam is a as a we're very well known
record label especially it was very well
known for its hip-hop artists back in
the day such as from Run DMC LL Cool J
these are some of the artists that wore
on their back in the day so a lot of
people know for that the heart itself is
searching for the truth sometimes
without the individual realizing it but
what happens is that we become so busy
and I was just having this conversation
with another brother about how Shaitaan
makes us so busy in our lives
you know whether it be with music once
again movies you're watching you know
people that are glued to the TV
literally becoming a zombie we become so
busy in our lifestyle that we don't
realize the heart is literally screaming
out and screaming for guidance so the
difference between my heart then
announce it's no comparison I'm telling
you like anyone that knew me before and
knows me now they see a big difference
you know and it's missing not to brag
about myself or anything but this is
this this is the calmness and the peace
that I have or the loss of Hannah Witton
holla
today it's it's a big difference and I
can I can't say enough to be grateful
you know I can't say enough to think a
lot honestly man I mean I think about it
every day how Allah literally took me
away from that environment I was around
literally if I wanted to right now you
know I'm someone that can go right back
to what I was doing again and in
literally with all this technology today
and make millions of dollars without a
record label you know it's it's just
talking about how it's so much easier to
do those things but I know in my heart
those things are temporary enjoyments
and they're gonna do nothing but destroy
me
it's as simple as that to simplify its
going to absolutely destroy me and
that's what I was on a path of
destruction without a doubt without a
doubt
importance of seeking knowledge so that
you worship your creator upon clarity
like you said it gives you that clarity
you're able to see the the false from
that which is real you understand
and that night brings us to a point when
I was about seventeen someone told me I
had a cross I had a cross on my neck
when I was about 17 and one of my
friends told me you had that you have a
catheter cross in your neck and I said
what do you mean I said what's the
difference I didn't have knowledge so
that lightbulb I had that lightbulb
effect that people talked about and so I
started to read the Bible I started to
ponder on the Bible myself which we
mentioned that most people don't do why
because of that that hidden hypnosis
effect that they have that hypnotic
effect that they're under but because
you're jumping dancing hopping around
and so when a person goes to read the
Bible you fall asleep because now you're
in search of knowledge so finding that
knowledge searching for that knowledge
myself first I see that what Jesus
worships to create it
Moses worship the Creator rose in the
air and fallen on their face and
worshiping the Creator Jesus peace be
upon him saying the one that sent me is
greater than I the one that sent me is
greater than all I said hold on I want
to worship who they're worshiping so
this gives once again knowledge equals
clarity as you mentioned as simple as
that
just like myself I was somebody that had
a cross on my neck used to walk around
with these things but it was more like
you felt like it's some type of good
luck symbol kind of thing as you can see
and myself as well as many others they
don't know what that stands for they
don't have the knowledge that comes
along with it okay what what is the
belief system that comes along with it
we didn't know majority I would say the
majority of Christian brothers and
sisters they don't they just don't know
they don't have knowledge of what their
parents are following and that was me I
was in those shoes I didn't have
knowledge of of the Bible I didn't have
knowledge of Jesus peace be upon himself
or our belief system and so once you
have these are this is just misguided so
once again they're wearing it I believe
that where many of them
wearing it for the same reasons I was so
from working with Keyshia Cole Bruno
Mars had you get a chance to talk about
now that you change your life
there is usually amongst musicians
who've just filled their heart with
music constantly drugs alcohol and you
see a lot of them committing at when
they rise to the top you see there's no
peace there really the heart is yearning
for some house and they commit suicide
antidepressants drugs alcoholism and and
this is actually there's a statistic
that it's it's much higher suicide rate
is much higher
amongst famous writers and artists this
is known as statistic tell us now did
you get a chance to relay some of this
information to them yes I have spoken
with a few friends of mine within the
music industry and some of them know
Islam is the truth you know I haven't
personally got the chance to see I
haven't seen Bruno in a long time it's
been a few years since I've seen him
Keyshia haven't seen her in years also
because I kind of like drifted off of
the scene but now since I've been back
here in the US there's people that I
want to reach out to again and really
talk to them because I know that many
people are starving for the knowledge so
a lot of them yes I've had the
opportunity to give them dower and
invite them to Islam and I believe many
of them know Islam is the truth in fact
one of my friends who was he was the in
Arabic Warner Brothers at the time or
Motown you know he no it's Nam is a true
but that lifestyle becomes a fitna for
them becomes a trial where they they see
they okay if I embrace Islam was listen
X kind of thing you understand so it and
there's a lot of singer musicians out
there who are Muslim but it's very
difficult for them to get away from that
lifestyle also and it's very difficult
for them to come out publicly and
publicly and say who they are you know
so they're dealing with that as well
the statement of the man I'll claim
josiya or him home law he mentioned that
the Quran and music and it can't be in
the same heart at the same time you
can't love music and love the Quran at
the same time there they're gonna be at
war with one another so you know it's
it's definitely a hindrance you know you
may not a person may not feel the same
when they were citing in the Salah it's
a big difference you know it may it may
make you hate listening to lectures and
things like that a person that's
addicted to music you know when a person
is dying they may be singing a song
instead of reciting the Kalima it's very
dangerous very dangerous so while I take
a chance I take a chance on something
and there's something when you know we
know I know that is definitely a trial
without without a doubt is more
addictive than probably drinking alcohol
or is more addictive than then then then
trying to get away from smoking
cigarettes or things like it's more
addictive than that I believe it so it's
a step by step process
no one's gonna probably get rid of it
all all you know you know all at once
but take the steps necessary show Allah
that you know that you're at least
taking the steps you know you know
Amma's most forgiving most merciful so
and and and most importantly I would say
with that is to ask Allah to assist us
when we have those addictions acids
actually created to assist you ask Allah
for guidance even if we're not Muslim
for example the best thing we can do is
ask the creative the hem as a nerve you
know even if you don't believe that a
Creator exists say Oh God guide me to
that way which you are pleased with
guide me to your way without a doubt
Allah is going to guide you to Islam the
Creator is gonna guide you to Islam if
that person sincerely ask the creator of
the heavens and earth to guide them
people God so likewise if a person
sincerely ask Allah to guide them away
from music they will without a doubt
Allah was system and I will show them a
better way
women are very vulnerable in the society
as we see that there they're used for
for you know they're they're degraded in
the society already as we see so this is
another way you know from my point of
view to degrade women because once
you're able to to to to have them swing
and and and have them think in a certain
way you know it's there over for that
time they open for their attack and this
opens you up to on a deeper level to Jim
possession and all kinds of things when
we when we are becoming so aroused what
music it opens people up and that's a
whole nother topic in itself how people
become under possession without
realizing it because they are in a state
of this such a state of arousal or anger
or you know whatever it may be this
state of arousing it's a problem that
just opens you up for so many different
things in this society being a version
it's frowned upon why it's because of
what the people are listening to with
they're being conditioned with they are
being dumbed down so I mean they're
turning into zombies so when you have
these type of songs they're still
calling the youth to the disobedience of
Allah whether with the with the children
the youth are started to be very
disrespectful to the parents and the
parents don't understand why have you
have you examined with what they're
allowed to listen to what do you allow
them to listen to so and I'll just just
a quick question and everyone has the
question this if you listen to music if
a person listens to music accident how
many verses of the Quran have they
memorized is the Quran difficult for
them to memorize if so then you know why
then you know why I've met people in
Egypt brother Eddie and there was a
brother listening to music he was
addicted to it I saw he was addicted to
it and accident how many verses of the
Quran had he memorized how many Saudis
he had memorized and keep in mind that
you have many people to have memorized
the Quran in Egypt his brother had
memorized for Soros his whole life
and he told me I said I said have you
been listening to music since you were a
child
he said yes I've been listen doing this
listening to it and I he said I'm
addicted to it you know I said this is
the reason this is the reason so anyone
that has that same problem look at just
look at the opposite the Quran and see
how how much time you spend with the
Quran and you see that shape on is
trying to take you away from Allah
clearly